imagine getting called out for cheating
now imagine getting caught streaming
with your hacks on but that's exactly
what happened to plexify vanguard's
number two ranked player when he
accidentally revealed his hacks while he
was live on stream damn on that kid
cutie i caught it damn my game always
crashes but according to him he only had
the cheats on to grind for camos and
didn't know how to turn them off
afterwards
he also said that he achieved rank two
legitimately and then use the cheats
yeah but this issue doesn't end with
plexify hacking has been rampant in card
ever since crossplay was enabled oh yeah
you can see the guy running and
man they got caught in super 8k dolby
atmos now call of duty have tried to
address all of this with their
anti-cheat ricochet which came out in
december 2021 for warzone and earlier
this year for vanguard but that hasn't
really stopped the hacks